welcome back to new rockstars i'm winnie
van laningham and after seeing just how
much the public knows about the
adventures and exploits of first
mightiest heroes at avengercon i gotta
know how much of the mcu is common
knowledge within its own canon in an
interview with marvel.com executive
producer sana amanot explained her take
on what the public knows about endgame
at the khan she said quote people might
know some things but they don't know all
the things they don't know everyone's
actual code name or their real name
because it's the ground's eye view of
the marvel universe these are just
regular civilians putting this
convention together but us viewers at
home aren't normies babies so let's
break down exactly how and what these
civvies know about their own universe
the earliest traceable point of public
avengers knowledge in the mcu was the
wartime propaganda centered around
captain america from his uso tour to
comic books the star-spangled man with a
plan became a deep and popular part of
the united states of mcu america's
cultural identity seeing as avengers con
touts its location at camp lehigh as the
home of captain america and counting the
numerous star-spangled singer cosplayers
that attend it it's fair to say that
some version of cap's wartime mythos
still permeates the public consciousness
of feige 616. we can actually fast
forward through most of phase one and
two from here while plenty of events
such as the battle of new york or
aldrich killian's kidnapping of
president ellis would have obviously
drawn global coverage smaller events
such as thor's battle against the
destroyer in new mexico could
potentially be public knowledge now
thanks to black widow in the winter
soldier natasha dumped shield's entire
database to counter hydra's uprising
during her public testimony with the
department of defense she was accused of
laying waste to the us's entire
intelligence apparatus which gives us a
rough sense of how many mcu origin
stories would be public knowledge as
long as coulson galaga guy or some other
shield agent wrote up a briefing it
stands to reason that plenty of
first-hand accounts throughout shield's
history are accessible to civilians even
if damage control was done to delete
these files there would still likely be
a cottage industry of reporters
historians and youtubers with file
copies to share although this shield
leak doesn't necessarily cover
everything in falcon in the winter
soldier for instance we learned that
isaiah bradley's existence imprisonment
and forced experimentations were swept
under the rug according to bucky this
information was kept even from steve
while bradley was technically us army
not shield he did combat hydra and the
winter soldier so it would be logical
for shield to have files on america's
second super soldier it seems likely
that certain events particularly ones
that highlight government-sanctioned
atrocities could have been scrubbed from
the record or done entirely off the
books prior to natasha's leap moving
further into phase two we have a handful
of notable events that would get basic
news coverage the transpirings of age of
ultron from hulk's rampage in
johannesburg to ultron's annihilation of
sokovia would all get major worldwide
coverage these events in addition to the
casualties incurred in the botched lagos
mission would swing a sizable portion of
public opinion against the avengers and
ultimately led to the un drafting the
sokovia accords it's hard to say how
much detailed knowledge reporters would
have on these incidents but with
pressures of accountability racking tony
with guilt i can see him being as
transparent as he was when he revealed
the death tolls that built stark
industries back in iron man based on jim
coach andre wilson's remarks in
homecoming the fallout of civil war
might be somewhat shrouded in mystery to
the public he says that he's pretty sure
that cap is a war criminal now hinting
that the world might not know the
details of the avengers big breakup but
they definitely can piece together that
it was a result of the accords in the
same scene liz allen says that security
footage of the airport battle was
uploaded to youtube based on my
experience with youtube cctv footage of
an avengers battle royale is exactly the
type of video to get over a billion
views the majority of phase three
between civil war and end game is
off-world or self-contained so it's
likely that the public doesn't have a
super clear understanding of these
events the happenings of doctor strange
for instance are unlikely to be public
knowledge as almost nothing in that
movie occurs in the open we know that
spider-man does have a local and online
following at this point but considering
that peter's secret identity is a vital
part of his character i don't think that
the minutia of his heroics is well known
the biggest global news headline during
this period would definitely be wakanda
coming out of isolation while t'challa
is willing to share their technological
advances with the world i think anything
regarding killmonger's coup is probably
kept purposefully vague or secret for
national security reasons this brings us
to infinity war and the era of the blimp
one of the most interesting easter eggs
to come out of the first episode of ms
marvel is a sign advertising the release
of a memoir titled i was there that
supposedly outlines what happened during
the battle of earth this is definitely a
blink and you'll miss at detail but
thankfully the folks at marvel helped
fill in some of the blanks for us
according to an article posted on
marvel.com i was there as a post-endgame
autobiographical story written by an
anonymous shield agent who was
apparently right in the middle of the
action it contains an interview with
hawkeye about the battle and details the
clash between the heroes of earth and
the alien scourge threatening our
fragile planet the author also boasts a
first-hand account of tony stark using
the infinity gauntlet however marvel.com
tells us that this is a point of
contention as a shield agent in question
was apparently 6 000 feet away when tony
did the final snap sidequest if they
really were there this person is a huge
bag of dicks for not clueing in nick
fury and far from home we learned that
he came back from the blip with no team
no intel and a high school kid dodging
his calls mystery homie if you're a
shield agent and you're not immediately
giving fury the lowdown i pity you
because he's gonna find out who you are
and hit you with a deeply uncomfortable
glare but this agent isn't the only one
from the battlefield talking about
endgame in addition to their interview
with hawkeye kamala herself tells us
that scott lang also has a podcast
detailing the battle of earth in my head
canon luis is his fast-talking podcast
co-host who tells us all the crazy
stupid fine details of their conquest he
would crush that gig and you can do it
from home if you're a convicted felon it
seems like ant-man really went into
detail talking about each hero's role in
the fight against thanos enough that
sloth baby productions was able to crank
out a 10 video series about them i think
it's highly likely that other avengers
have shared their sides of the story
along the way as well beyond what we've
learned from ms marvel there are a few
other potential information pipelines
that could have publicized the battle of
earth and the battle of wakanda within
the context of endgame captain america
led a grief support group for blip
survivors where i imagine he probably
opened up about the events in order to
help others find closure about what
happened to their loved ones we also saw
posters advertising brief support groups
and even blip survivor dating apps in
shanghai so his influence clearly spread
to other parts of the us then we have
professor hulk who's approached by
children and photographed leading me to
believe that he's garnered some amount
of attention for his role in saving the
world since merging dr banner and the
other guy we know that thor already
refused to say thanos's name or speak of
the incident due to his post-traumatic
stress so i don't think that he spoke to
any news outlets but i don't know man
that dude was sad and drunk as hell and
i do think that it's possible that he
unloaded his grief on a poor
unsuspecting gamer at some point and
according to that avengers con article
on marvel.com there's also a book for
sale there called carol a definitive
account of the cosmic avenger a book
aimed to unfold the true identity of
captain marvel this tells me that
someone must have gotten up close and
personal to her too based on some of the
media surrounding the guardians of the
galaxy i don't think that any of them
give specific interviews although i'm
sure star-lord would have loved to give
his thoughts on footloose to any
reporter writer or citizen who asked at
the table where the drax cosplayer is
posted up you can see a dvd case for a
pal to all planets the peter quill
starboy story according to marvel.com
this is a 40-minute docu-series that
promises to show viewers wonders beyond
imagination as quill journeys through
the universe in search of his home in
addition to this dvd calling peter
starboy we also see a t-shirt featuring
brute as mr tree and a display setup
called trash panda alley in honor of
rocket all of their names are completely
made up lending to the idea that no
third party has spoken directly to them
we did see nebula getting used by thanos
as a human projector and end game
however so clearly her cybernetic parts
have visual and audio recording
capabilities which can be replayed at
any time her account is technically
preserved should any future dvd makers
want to know what happened from her
perspective but the likelihood of her
complying with such requests seems slim
to none but other third parties have
also made content to explain the
aftermath of infinity war and endgame
for example there's paul greengrass
director of the snap the in-flight
entertainment option on peter's plane
ride to europe and far from home in real
life greengrass is a director known for
dramatizations of significant historical
events such as united 93 the docudrama
about the attack on 9 11. then there's
heart of iron the tony stark story a
feature-length documentary that
chronicles the life and legacy left
behind by the world's greatest hero tony
stark my theory about this doc is that
the people who worked on it were made
privy to tony's personal story via stark
tech we learned in homecoming
pre-infinity war that peter's spidey
suits training wheels protocol also came
with the baby monitor protocol and my
guess is that all of tony's other suits
also have this feature minus the
intentionally demeaning code names i
mean these suits are decked out in every
way imaginable including hd targeting
and visual interfacing tech why wouldn't
all of tony's suits come with a record
feature in the very beginning he used to
tape himself testing out each new suit
design and realized somewhere down the
line that it would also be helpful to
see himself in action not only is he a
huge narcissist who probably plays back
all of his fight sequences just to see
how badass he looks by the time end game
happened i bet every single one of his
suits were outfitted with recording
capabilities spider-man iron man war
machine the hulk buster and rescue were
all front and center of the battle so
their suits would have caught all the
action it's possible that in the
aftermath of tony's death stark
industries was compelled to share their
findings with the us government or maybe
even the united nations because if i
were a world leader i would definitely
demand to know what the hell evil daddy
grimace was doing with those deadly
gushers on his glove even if pepper
didn't want to give up her partner's
tech she may not have had a choice the
entire world wanted to know exactly what
happened and she may have had to show
select people and power those tapes then
there's the real possibility of
disgruntled stark employees like
mysterio and his crew leaking these
recordings far from home made it clear
that plenty of stark employees didn't
see eye to eye with their boss so it's
not a huge stretch to think that an
insider could have leaked files and
footage heck man it could even be a
member of quentin beck's crew once they
got control of stark's network of
satellites thanks to peter handing over
eda they'd presumably also get access to
these files considering that they'd be
in orbit of a massively public court
trial thanks to beck outing and avengers
identity it stands to reason that one of
these cunning nerds could have traded
backup copies of stark footage for
judicial leniency and this may be where
the dodc comes in we know that they
seized stark assets after spider-man was
doxed by mysterio and now they've been
working to hunt down new persons with
enhanced capabilities with marvel
releasing armor wars sometime in 2023
this confiscated stark tech with
potential video footage from the
avengers various battles might come back
to haunt us down the line i'm also
curious to know how many people are
aware of exactly what happened in west
view new jersey obviously darcy monica
and jimmy have binge-watched wandavision
and other members of sword were also
there when wanda's reality was broadcast
to their tv sets outside of the hex but
i wonder if any of the mcu civilians
have seen my favorite show i mean
realistically i don't think that 616's
disney plus bought the rights to a
woman's grief and packaged it for
regular folks but the details of wanda's
telecasting leave some wiggle room for
additional onlookers according to
wandavision's showrunner jack schaefer
wanda was subconsciously editing scoring
and producing her show as a cry for help
to do so darcy says that the hex emitted
extremely high levels of cosmic
microwave background radiation with a
broadcast frequency embedded within it
all it took was a cathode ray television
with a pair of rabbit ears to hone in to
this over-the-air signal hypothetically
anyone with a similar setup could tune
into one division and considering
wanda's power level the strength of this
broadcast frequency could reasonably
range across the globe there's a
non-zero chance that someone other than
from sword has seen wanda show which was
running up until wanda cuts off the
signal irl in episode vii additionally
westview hostages must have gone on the
record at some point after they were
released it's not every day that you get
kidnapped by a superhero infused with an
infinity stone so i'm sure that at the
very very least some teenager from that
town made a tick talk about their
experience and like i said organizations
like shield and hydra have had
classified docs leaked from within in
the past it's also possible that someone
from sword will eventually come forward
especially after wanda almost destroyed
reality a second time in multiverse of
madness this potential leak could
explain why bruno and kamala called the
light up gloves for her cosplay photon
gloves that's a capital p in the
subtitles suggesting this is a proper
noun this might be a stretch because
photon isn't just monica rambo's call
sign it's a regular old science word but
what if ms marvel knew to call them
photon with a capital p gloves because
of leaked information about monica from
westfield we also see kamala fall back
into bed upright when she's fantasizing
about her upcoming evening at avengercon
a move that mirrors one of the
commercials for nexus antidepressants in
wondervision could she have copied this
style in her daydream because she saw
this ad somehow again i could totally be
reading way too much into these details
but it would be really interesting if
one division made its way to the public
we also have to give credit to the
average citizens themselves for their
own first-hand recording of encounters
with the avengers like in real life
everyone in the mcu is constantly glued
to their televised news cell phones and
social media just like you are right now
hello i am yourself bleep larp charge me
thank you
thanks to the vast array of canon media
outlets in the mcu the general
population has always had a fairly solid
idea of what happened during each of the
battles that have occurred over the last
several years the footage shown on the
news on live streams on youtube and
print media always comes from regular
humans experiencing these events their
knowledge however is limited compared to
what we know as fans and to what the
characters themselves have gone through
in universe like sarah amanot said they
don't know everything for example there
probably wasn't anyone tweeting during
shangshi's dragon fight with his dad and
talo so only a few select people know
him as a world hero but everyone from
san francisco to macau knows who bus guy
is thanks to the dude who live streamed
the fight on his cell phone and then of
course there's flashpoint a truly
limited edition memoir written by flash
thompson that definitely vanished along
with all that sweet sweet royalty money
the second that the world forgot about
peter parker flash like the shield agent
who published i was there was able to
capitalize on his book because he truly
had the receipts to back up his writing
this dude has been instagramming and
live streaming all of their classmates
adventures and even though we know that
he doesn't know jack [ __ ] about
spider-man or peter he's able to easily
convince the world that he's spidey's
best friend because he has convincing
proof so far in ms marvel we've already
seen the video of her saving that little
boy on the minaret go viral and my guess
is that it won't be the last time our
girl ends up on social media this season
not only is kamala obsessed with youtube
her teenage peers are glued to the
internet that popular girl zoe is even
an influencer it's like mysterio said
the story you created is totally
ridiculous and apparently exactly the
kind of thing that people will believe
right now after all the crazy [ __ ] that
the people of earth have witnessed in
the mcu's lifespan
of course they'll believe anybody who
offers even the slightest proof that
they know what's up with these
superheroes and based on everything that
we saw at avengercon i think it's pretty
safe to say that most of these humans
are using their imaginations to fill in
the gaps that scotland's podcast just
can't fill follow me on instagram and
twitter at whitney puppy follow new
rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you